[busy street sounds]
[rhythmic music playing]
AMAN SETHI: Everyone buys
water from the water mafia--
the rich, the poor,
the middle class.
That's because Delhi
and its surroundings
have about 24 million people.
And anywhere between
30% to 40% don't
have access to municipal water.
And as the black market water
trade became more organized,
the trucks got
bigger, the people who
were controlling it got richer.
Now the water mafia
behaves in a way
that this water
will last forever,
but as temperatures
continue to rise,
the mafia is finally
going to run out of water.
And that's when we're really
going to have a problem.
AARON WOLF
(VOICEOVER): The status
of the world's fresh water
supply today is a crisis as
big as anything out there.
[people arguing in non-english]
Less than 1% of
the world's water
is accessible for human use.
Populations are going up.
As economies grow and
countries develop,
they use more and more water.
And we're polluting
what is, making
it less and less accessible.
[PEOPLE ARGUING LOUDLY IN NON
ENGLISH]
MARCUS KING (VOICEOVER):
Water scarcity is with us here
and now.
Warmer temperatures,
less predictable rains
will all combine to make
societies a little less stable.
AARON WOLF: People
generally have three sets
of responses to water scarcity.
They can adapt if they have
the resources, they can move,
or they can suffer and die.
And if they're
moving, this becomes
a security concern worldwide.